l'été va-t-il enfin laisser place à
l'automne on peut se poser la question
et oui on nous l'annonce à partir de ce
weekend mais les températures
exceptionnelles de ces derniers jours et
plus généralement depuis la rentrée
interroge c'était l'objet de notre
question web justement ce soleil qui
joue les prolongations vous
inquiète-t-il et c'est le cas pour 61 %
d'entre vous vous êtes à contrario 14 %
à vous en réjouir fataliste vous en
profitez pour un quart d'entre vous et
justement Michel comment la nature
réagit-elle à cet été indien Léa Turquie
est Lucas Chopin sont allés dans les
jardins de vilandri ce que l'on y
observe sans surprise une végétation
plus estivale cotonale
[Musique]
regardez à villandri les tomates
continuent de mûir ici on récolte encore
de nombreux légumes bref tout est en
décalage on retrouve Anthony Coué le
jardinier en chef pour quelques
explications est-ce que c'est un mois
d'octobre normal ici alors c'est pas un
mois d'octobre normal la dernière taille
qu'on fait sur les pas par exemple ça va
être au mois de septembre et là on est
au mois d'octobre et en fait on continue
à tailler parce qu'en fait il continu à
pousser on continue comme si on était en
saison en fait vous me parliez de
quelques fleurs aussi qui avaent
quelques changement par rapport au mois
d'octobre habituel est-ce qu'on va les
voir donc on va aller voir les fleurs
oui qui se portent très bien et qui a de
la couleur et qui sont qui sont en
pleine forme en fait on y
[Musique]
va donc là on est dans le jardin de la
musique les sont plus vives que
d'habitude on s'aperçoit vraiment que
les les sauges qui sont juste derrière
nous bleus là sont vraiment pas
défleoris en fait donc ils ont pas subi
ni de froid ni de d'intempérie on va
dire avec la pluie et une une activité
auprès des abeilles et des bourdons qui
qui est vraiment très actif que
d'habitude au mois d'octobre mi-octobre
on n pas elle est pas aussi active donc
là on a vraiment on a vraiment les
presque 3 semaines on va dire de
décalage parce que normalement début
octobre le jardin décline et là on est
mioctobre et là il ne décline pas du
tout
[Musique]
de nombreuses conséquences pour un été
qui n'en finit plus les températures
devraient finalement baisser dans les
prochains jours cette semaine météo
France annonce un écart de 10°grés avec
les normales de saison d'un mois
d'octobre en
Touren